tonight on the new reality we had an
avalanche of lying from president trump
how did a canadian reporter become
fact-checker-in-chief to the american
commander-in-chief
it sort of took on a life of its own
because of frankly how much lying
he does trump is again sowing doubt
based on no evidence that the election
won't be free and fair
this level of voter suppression we have
not seen
this is a new threat to american
democracy
the canadian government has been bracing
for november 3rd
and the uncertainty that could follow if
he thinks confusion and chaos
can help him hang on i think there's
every prospect he'll engage
hello i'm donna friesen welcome to
washington d.c
we're here because the us is on the cusp
of making a pivotal decision in its
political history
plenty of journalists have covered
president trump over the last four years
but
only one has consistently relentlessly
fact-checked him
and he's canadian his name is daniel
dale
when he spots a lie he calls it a lie
that might sound simple but
hardly anyone in this town does it dale
started calling out politicians when he
was a toronto city hall reporter back in
the rob ford era
now he's at cnn he told me being
canadian gives him more freedom to do
what he does and what he does isn't easy
let's talk about some facts here's our
fact checker daniel dale the
hardest working man in the news business
he is straightforward
it's almost too stupid to fact check
unassuming i'm just enjoying listening
to your conversation
and fearless we had an avalanche of
lying
from president trump for five years
canadian journalist daniel dale has
listened to or
read transcripts of almost every public
event where president trump has spoken
i never aspired to be a fact checker i
never aspired to be on tv i thought
i would be a canadian print reporter my
entire career i was at the toronto star
and i thought i'd stayed there for
for years or decades and i started fact
checking trump and it sort of took on a
life of its own because of
frankly how much lying he does we're
always protecting
people with pre-existing conditions
chris he's in court as you know right
now trying to kill those protections in
obamacare with no replacement plan
i brought back 700 000 jobs they brought
back nothing they gave up on
manufacturing
so everything about that claim wolf is
inaccurate as we get closer to
election dates whether it is this
election or the 2018 midterms
in addition to the ad-libbed impromptu
lies that that he is known for
there start to be more lies written into
his speeches
what do you think is behind that i think
trump and his campaign know that they
can get
inaccurate false information to
millions of people unfiltered because
the outlets
that these people are consuming are not
fact-checking him
dale's live tirades of truth after a
litany of lies
often leave his cnn colleagues
speechless this one went on
for more than three minutes trump said i
have done more for the african-american
community than any president since
abraham lincoln that is ludicrous
he said he'll quote continue to lower
drug prices they've increased
during his presidency he said democrats
want to defund the police
biden again doesn't has rejected that
and he said that biden's plan
would eliminate america's borders no
just no
it's wrong oh that's it
there's more wow how much time do you
got anderson
it's a full-time job dale has built a
searchable database to keep track of it
all
at last count he says he's documented
more than 9 000 false claims
it's sorted by claim and by category and
by date and by
type of event and so when trump says
something
for the you know 30th or 50th or 100th
time i can tell you you know that was
the
78th time trump made that claim how did
a canadian reporter become
fact checker in chief to the american
commander-in-chief
it all started with rob ford the erratic
crack smoking now deceased former mayor
of toronto
dale then a city hall reporter with the
toronto star was investigating a real
estate deal ford was involved in
and the mayor came out and confronted me
and chased me with a raised fist it was
very strange
anyway he then went on television and
essentially accused me of being a
pedophile
dale sued him ford eventually retracted
his words
i wish to sincerely apologize again to
mr dale
if my actual words have caused him any
harm
or personal offense dale wrote this
column about it
rob ford is lying about me and it's vile
it was the first time he called a
politician a liar in print
and so i gradually started using the
word lie for other
false things that ford was saying and
then you know when i
moved to dc in 2015 started covering
trump and then when trump started lying
um it was kind of a no-brainer for me at
that point you know
i use the word lie covering ford why
can't i use it covering trump
he says he's got plenty of haters but he
has lots of fans
too danny updale is for my purposes the
most important
reporter really in the world right now
eric alterman is a journalist professor
and the author of 11 books
including lying in state why presidents
lie
and why trump is worse why do you think
that
other media outlets do not cover
president trump that way do not
call out his lies the way daniel dale
does
he didn't grow up in this media culture
that is so deferential to the president
that they're afraid to call a lie a lie
do you think being a canadian and daniel
makes a difference
in in how you're approaching this i i
think it does
um i think being canadian and working
for a canadian outlet at first
at the toronto star gave me a level of
freedom that many american reporters and
american outlets
did not have i'm not like worried oh i'm
you know but by using this kind of
language by being straightforward
i'm jeopardizing my future in the in the
american media we're rounding the turn
on the pandemic
dale says as election day approaches the
more trump amps up
the false claims biden was imperfect uh
there were at least a few false
misleading or lacking in context claims
from him
but for a fact checker you're kind of
sitting there with biden occasionally
you're like oh that's wrong
with trump you're like that i love lucy
episode in the chocolate factory you
know you don't know
which one to pick up because there's
just so much and so again with this
president we just see
a constant barrage incessantly of false
or misleading stuff
does it ever just make your head
explode you know i'm fine
people express serious concern about my
mental health honestly i get
i'll get emails um certainly tweets
being like are you are you okay or
you want to contribute to your vacation
fund he does have plans to take a beach
vacation
after november third and what if trump
wins do you think you can keep this up
for another four years
i i don't know uh i it is hard for me to
envision doing this for
four more years
though the rest of the world can't cast
a ballot it does feel like there's a lot
at stake for all of us in this
presidential election
donald trump has upended not just the
american political establishment
he has disrupted relationships with
america's allies
and now while we're all still caught up
in a pandemic
the future of the united states seems
uncertain
why does he refuse to commit to a
peaceful transition of power should he
lose and
why so mistrust in the most basic
functions of a democratic society
[Applause]
it was undisguised ambition that
descended that golden escalator at trump
tower in 2015
people thought it was a sideshow or a pr
stunt
it wasn't the american dream
is dead politicians
are all talk no action they will not
bring us
believe me to the promised land
from the beginning donald trump has
portrayed himself as the only man who
can save america
i'm so smart i am the most brilliant
human being that has ever lived
his style his message have been
consistent from the start
i spoke with sarah kenzier one of the
few journalists who back in 2015
predicted trump would win trump did not
emerge in a vacuum
our institutions were badly battered by
the time he came into office but what he
then did
was exacerbate all the worst tendencies
of american life
american politics kenzior is an
anthropologist who studies authoritarian
regimes her latest book is called hiding
in plain sight
and in it she says trump ran his
campaign like an autocrat in waiting
and has governed like one ever since we
do not have a government we have a
transnational crime syndicate
masquerading as a government
it doesn't even pretend at this point to
serve the american people
to do things for the public good it's
just about his
self-enrichment and protecting himself
and his cronies from
criminal prosecution he has scapegoated
immigrants and minorities
these aren't people these are animals
threatened journalists our media is the
enemy
of the people vowed to repeal rights and
protections
we have to have a temporary ban on
muslims coming into this country i'm
sorry
incited violence knock the crap out of
her would you seriously
and he's insulted his closest allies
calling canadian prime minister justin
trudeau very dishonest and weak
and he's openly admired dictators he
wrote me beautiful letters
and they're great letters we fell in
love
all or authoritarian tactics and
president trump used those tactics to
take over the republican party
and has taken the u.s and the world on a
wild ride
a ride that might not be over now
everything is partisan and so if the
republicans are controlling the senate
republicans are controlling the supreme
court
then there really isn't a possible way
to oversee
a president who's breaking norms of
democracy breaking rules of democracy
and sometimes breaking the laws
i think mail-in voting is is going to
rig the election i really do
as he did in 2016 trump is against
sowing doubt based on no
evidence that the election won't be free
and fair
when the real more insidious problem is
voter suppression
laws and policies that make it hard for
certain people to cast a ballot
dexter voice in is the dean of the
faculty of social work
at the university of toronto and author
of america the beautiful
and violent many of these suppression
tactics
removal of poll boxes limiting polling
sites
purging individuals from the rolls
all things that disproportionately
impact black and wrong individuals and
poor whites in america
this level of voter suppression we have
not seen
particularly coming from the white house
this this is a new territory
and a new threat to american democracy
it can sound
alarmist far-fetched impossible in the
land of the free in the home of the
brave
but the theory of american
exceptionalism the belief the u.s
follows a different path than other
nations is being tested
i can't think of anything else he's
talking about more than
uh sowing doubt about the election
result that's to come
he's he's undermining the election he's
making it so that
millions of his supporters if he loses
will not believe the result
and that's incredibly dangerous and
democracy
is fragile democracy's hard to retain
and most of the world lives under
authoritarian regimes
we should be under no illusion that
america is somehow
wildly different from the rest of the
world and
we have to be vigilant and just
not be naive and if people are vigilant
and not naive
america has the institutions and the
population to resist
an authoritarian takeover trump has
millions of fervent supporters who want
four more years but millions of other
americans
are scared right now we are afraid um
we're afraid of the pandemic we're
afraid of authoritarianism and we're
afraid of
mass violence and all three of those are
very real and ongoing threats
instead of condemning white supremacists
trump seemed to send them a signal
boys stand back and stand by
he said if he loses it's because his
opponents cheated
and he refuses to say if he'll concede
will you commit to making sure that
there is a peaceful transferal of power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster he's a man of his word as far
as his promises go
when he says he will stay in office
believe it he'll try to stay in office
authoritarians always tell you what
they're going to do and it's a great
mistake
not to take them at their word none of
us of course have a crystal ball
but sarah if you can look ahead to
november
3rd um what do you see
uh there's really no limits as to what
can happen you know i hope that none of
this happens like i
i hope i'm wrong about everything and
that you know we managed to
to move forward in a peaceful way but
just i don't think it's realistic to
expect that um given everything that's
happened in the last four years
and given the fact that trump encourages
violence
um you know and steadily has encouraged
violence and if he feels like he's a
martyr
if he feels like he has you know been
targeted and he's lost
he will encourage his most violent
followers to rise up
and attack people it seems so unlikely
in the land of liberty
it could be there's a landslide that
leaves no doubt on election night
or a close result and a loser who
rejects the outcome
this is 2020 and it feels like anything
is possible coming up on the new
reality in the corridors of power across
ottawa
planning for this election started early
so
how will canada respond if the result is
[Music]
unclear
canada has no bigger trading partner or
ally in defense and security
than the united states and what american
voters decide
in the u.s election will impact
canadians it's standard procedure for
our federal government to plan for every
potential outcome of a u.s
vote this time that planning has more
variables and more
wild cards than usual mercedes stevenson
reports on the extraordinary
preparations
and how canada's response will unfold
[Applause]
unconventional wildly unpredictable
donald trump has shattered our
expectations
of normal and as the 2020 campaign draws
to an
end the president appears willing to
defy the most
basic of democratic norms can you give a
direct answer you will accept the
election
look you i have to see no i'm not going
to just say yes
for months trump has claimed the only
way he can lose
is if there's fraud john bolton
trump's own former national security
adviser
warns the president won't leave
graciously if defeated
if he thinks confusion and chaos
can help him hang on can help affect
recounts and contests
i think there's every prospect he'll
engage in
sources tell global news the canadian
government has been bracing for november
3rd
and the uncertainty that could follow in
the corridors of power across ottawa
planning for this election started early
it has been intense with a surge of
briefings
and intelligence reports preparing for
all scenarios
canada's embassy in washington will be
at the heart of the government's
response
ambassador kirsten hillman has been in
near
daily communication with the prime
minister's office
multiplying her contacts in the white
house congress
the state department and security
agencies like the fbi and cia
so how will canada respond if the result
is
unclear roland paris served as prime
minister trudeau's first
foreign policy and defense advisor he
says
if there's any doubt about who won the
election the prime minister would be
wise to keep his powder dry
canadian prime ministers rarely have
anything to gain
by involving themselves in u.s domestic
politics and they
often have quite a bit to lose aside
from reaffirming its confidence in the
u.s electoral process
canada will do everything it can to
avoid being drawn into the political
firestorm
raging south of the border
multiple sources told global news that
canada can't ignore the threat of civil
unrest and violence in the united states
one senior national security source said
the government
is quietly assessing the risk it could
spill over
into canada for 10 years
ward elcock served as canada's top spy
leading the canadian security
intelligence service
or csis there may well be some
some some people who do weird things in
the aftermath of the election
particularly if as
seems likely at this point mr trump
loses and loses badly
there may be some of his supporters who
who do get
pushed into to violent scenarios that
that are hard for us to imagine
earlier this month the u.s department of
homeland security
called white supremacists the most
persistent
and lethal threat to the country and
that threat is on canada's radar too
according to thomas juneau professor of
international affairs at the university
of ottawa
and a former analyst with the department
of national defense
one scenario that is always a nightmare
scenario for canada
is the issue of security threats coming
from canada crossing the canadian
american border
and reaching the u.s the fear on our
side is always that the response on the
american side will be to close the
border
which economically would be devastating
for us
speaking on the condition of anonymity a
former senior canadian intelligence
official said
agencies in canada will closely monitor
potential flash points
states like michigan where the fbi
recently foiled the militia plot earlier
this month
to kidnap the state's governor and
washington
where waves of protests may have
attracted more
far-right extremists canadian and
american intelligence and defense
operations are
so deeply intertwined any disruption to
that relationship
could be devastating so what if trump
were to issue wild orders in the
post-election chaos
like demanding u.s agencies cease all
intelligence sharing with allies several
intelligence sources said
the u.s defense and security apparatus
likely
won't take those orders if it considers
them illegitimate
trump may be disruptive but the us
military and
intelligence community is still run by
professionals
and they won't tow the president's line
if he goes rogue
and as erratic as trump may be few
experts think he'll barricade himself in
the oval
office and try to cling to power if he
loses
mr trump has been a blowhard most of his
time as president there's not much
reason to believe that he's suddenly
going to get courage as a result of of
being defeated especially if as seems
increasingly likely it's likely to be a
fairly major defeat
no matter what happens on november 3rd
the overwhelming consensus appears to be
that americans
and their institutions will find a way
to endure
this is not our first rodeo we've had
bitterly contested elections before
and we've gotten through it and we'll
get through this one too
welcome back we are only days away from
the u.s election and the united states
feels so divided global news will be
here to guide you through
election night join us tuesday night for
america votes 2020.
our coverage starts at 7 pm eastern time
on the global tv app
amazon prime video and on our website
globalnews.ca
and on youtube coverage will continue
here on global television at 11 p.m
local time
10 o'clock in manitoba and saskatchewan
the new reality will be back from
washington d.c
next week i'm donna friesen for now good
night
you